what would these characters look like if
they were titans which titan powers
would they inherit and how strong would
they be for example historia is a part
of the royal family so it would only be
fitting that she gets the powers of the
founding titan izayama once drew her as
a titan so based on that historious
titan would definitely look like a
divine being although having wings is a
bit peculiar in the case of titans it is
not entirely impossible as we saw that
falco's jaw titan has wings additionally
the new inheritors of the titan power
add their own mix to the appearance of
the titan so if astoria were to get the
power of the founder she would
definitely look like the angel she is
her overall appearance would resemble
that of a goddess and her powers would
also dictate that it's important to note
that the founding titan is pretty much
useless in the hands of non-royal blood
users since they can't unlock its powers
on their own however in historia's case
she doesn't require anyone else in order
to use all the abilities of her titan
and she would be practically unbeatable
she would easily be able to spawn any
titan she wills and even transform
herself into any other titan if she
chooses to same as aaron did when he
battled armin controlling titans would
be a piece of cake for her and she would
possess an army of her own as mentioned
before since astoria has royal blood she
can even command amir to change the
anatomy of the titans thereby giving
them more powers or reducing them she
could have amir make an army of flying
titans too another power she would
possess is the ability to control the
minds of the subjects of amir this power
on its own is pretty valuable and
dangerous if used correctly meaning she
can plant false memories remove existing
ones or control them as she wills now
that we've discussed the typical powers
that she would possess for the sake of
this video let's add our own twist as
she has the appearance similar to an
angel her body would radiate light
enough to blind enemies in a wide radius
the intense light itself would make her
a tough opponent to fight against to be
fair no one would be able to defeat
historia and the only ones that would
even stand a chance would be the other
founding titan inheritors which won't be
possible as there can only be one
founding titan at a time still
theoretically considering the idea the
only person powerful enough to go
against her would be amir fritz as she
was the first ever titan and most likely
the strongest one who would have thought
that someone as pure and cute as astoria
would be this dangerous i guess that
punch to levi was a threat he should
consider historia was only the first one
there are still four more interesting
titans to cover so let's continue with
mikasa ackerman mikasa is pretty much
incomparable to other soldiers in terms
of stamina strength and 3d maneuvering
skills she is also remarkable in
hand-to-hand combat and would need a
titan that is also swift like her and
doesn't slow her down keeping this in
mind i think we can all agree that
mikasa would make a killer female titan
as we've seen in season 1 the female
titan doesn't possess any unique powers
and instead it relies on its incredible
endurance and user's own fighting skills
this titan is literally made for
ackermanns mikasa is already a very
overpowered character capable of
defeating many titans including some
titan shifters only using her 3d gear
just imagine how powerful she would be
with the power of the titans so how
would mikasa look in this form and what
abilities would she have in terms of
appearance similar to annie mikasa would
definitely have feminine yet muscular
body of the female titan but with black
medium-length hair additionally she
would also have purple eyes that give
her a more sinister look typically the
female titan's powers don't have much of
a twist to them however in mikasa's case
her attacks would be accompanied by
purple shockwaves and should be able to
reverberate those shockwaves throughout
to her opponent's body which would make
her punches and kicks way more
destructive and powerful furthermore
mikasa's pure strength combined with the
power of the titans will allow her to
destroy huge buildings and structures
with absolute ease although mikasa would
be an exceptional fighter and titan
holder there are some titans that she
would not be able to defeat like the
colossal titan and the founding titan
it'll just be impossible for her to
reach the nape of the colossal titan
without getting burned to a crisp the
only way she would be able to defeat the
holder of this power would be if someone
else exhausts him beforehand similar to
what armin and aaron did in the anime
three more titans are left and the next
one is everyone's favorite scout levi
ackerman even though he doesn't possess
any titan powers this man right here is
the most broken character in aot so how
strong would he be as a titan shifter as
levi is the most badass scout in the
survey corps it's only fair and natural
that he gets the coolest titan of them
all the warhammer titan levi would
retain some of his human features in
this form including his hair and height
sorry levi but you would still be short
even as a titan shifter furthermore levi
as the warhammer titan would be a treat
to watch as he would use it in ways
we've never seen before in the anime the
warhammer titan is capable of using its
flesh to create all sorts of weapons and
basically anything the inheritor wishes
so do you know what that means we would
get to see a titan version of levi with
the weapons of his choice that being his
two iconic swords additionally levi
would use his abilities to the max
creating traps of spikes and using a
whip to tie up an opponent or pull them
closer to him if he gets even more
creative with it he might be able to
create the 3d maneuvering of gear as
well but it would be challenging to
operate it considering the titan's
height and the fuel requirement as the
warhammer titan levi would not be as
fast as he is in his human form but he
would still be a very destructive
fighter due to his unpredictable
fighting style he'd be able to defeat
any titan shifter that comes in his path
even the colossal titan would not stand
a chance against him as levi would
definitely find a way to use his powers
and terrain around him to his advantage
before we explain sasha who is in my
opinion the most interesting one let's
first quickly cover erwin we all know
how irwin died at the end of season
three it was indeed a heart-wrenching
scene that left all of us feeling sad
however if levi stuck to his original
choice and decided to sacrifice armin
the next one in line for inheriting the
colossal titan was definitely irwin due
to this particular scene it's only
appropriate that in this video irwin
inherits the colossal titan as the god
of destruction he would look quite
similar to bertholdt and there wouldn't
be many changes to his appearance
however when it comes to his abilities
you can bet irwin would use them in the
best way possible much better than any
titan shifter before him he would use
the titan's destructive nature by
appearing in places where the enemies
least expect him he won't just use his
abilities during fights with other
titans but also to strategically weaken
his opponents by destroying their
harbors and main routes of escape
similar to what armin did in season 4
being the crazy gambler he is he'd
probably use his powers in the most
risky ways possible always putting
himself in danger for the sake of the
plan furthermore he would use the
scorching steam of the colossal titan to
keep himself safe from any kind of harm
and burn any enemies that come too close
since the colossal titan is already
extremely powerful he wouldn't really
have many unique abilities of his own
it's important to notice that even when
irwin was a human powerful titan
shifters like reiner and bertholdt
acknowledged his strength and the
ability to easily change the tide of the
battle with his presence we can only
imagine how would marley feel if iron
was still alive and possessed the
colossal titan the destruction he would
cause in his eccentric ways huh i
definitely wouldn't want to be in
marley's position last but not least we
have our favorite potato girl sasha
brous if you ask me sasha is the true
star of the series even if she isn't
with us anymore in any case it's
important to give her a tribute by
talking about how she would be as a
titan shifter have you ever noticed that
sasha looks like a beast in the show at
times yeah me too and that's precisely
why she would be perfect for the role of
the beast titan so what's the catch here
the catch is that she won't be that
abnormal looking monkey like zeke no she
would be much more fierce kind of like
the lion sounds pretty cool right but
why a lion it's simple lions are
carnivores meaning that they pretty much
only eat meat and other animals although
sasha doesn't necessarily only eat meat
she is definitely a huge fan of it even
in her dying moments she was thinking
about having some meat the girl
definitely has her priorities straight
furthermore as the beast tighten she
would have the immense strength to take
down her prey in a matter of seconds and
eat it as well here the prey would
definitely be other titans and taking
them down would be a piece of cake for
her or a slice of meat sasha would be
one hell of a bloodthirsty beast titan
pouncing on the enemy as soon as she
lays eyes on them this would be an
excellent trait to have but would also
come with many repercussions it would
make her somewhat hard to control in
strategic situations as she would do
whatever she wants in her titan form it
would also make her a very predictable
target easy to take down with the right
plan someone like irwin would definitely
come up with interesting and unique ways
to lure her and trap her using bait she
definitely wouldn't be as strong as some
of the other shifters on this list but
there is no doubt that she would be a
fan favorite click on this video where
we covered 40 secret things you didn't
know about aaron jaeger